hello and welcome everyone to the active
inference live stream this is act in
stream 8.1 it is November 10th
2020 welcome to tecom everyone we are an
experiment in online team communication
learning and practice related to active
inference you can find us at our website
active inference org you can find us at
our Twitter at email our public keybase
team or on YouTube this is a recorded
and an archived live stream so please
provide us with feedback so that we can
improve our work all backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome here and as far
as video etiquette for live streams go
um mute yourself if there's noise in
your background raise your hands so that
we can hear from everybody on the stack
and use respectful speech Behavior ET
today we are excitingly in act mstream
8.1 and it's going to go a little
something like this we're going to start
with some intros and warm-ups and then
we'll get to the sections of
8.1 in 8.1 as well as 8.2 we're going to
be discussing the paper scaling active
inference by chance at all in 2019
thanks to Blue for the suggestion of the
paper we're going to go through the
goals the abstract and the road mapap
and then we'll have a little notation
and math overview we'll also take a look
at the figures with a special focus on
what each figure is showing or
representing or
invoking in today's discussion 8.1 and
next week's discussion 8.2 we're going
to be discussing this same paper so save
and submit your questions and also get
in touch with us if you want to
participate for the rest of 2020 we're
going to be discussing this paper 8 as
well as 9 10 and 11 would you can learn
more about by checking our Twitter so
check it out there all right here we are
in the intros welcome again Shannon I'll
kick out other
Shannon so for the introductions we'll
go around and just introduce yourself
and your location and we'll uh roll with
it as people gain and uh lose the chat
so just say hello in a short
introduction and then pass it to
somebody else I'm Daniel I'm in
California and I will pass it to
Blue hi I'm blue and I am in Southern
New Mexico in Las cruus and I will pass
it to
Sasha hi I'm Sasha I'm also in
California and um I will pass it to
Ivon hello my name is Ian I'm in Moscow
Russia and I pass it to Alejandra
I think she disappeared for a second so
let's go to Alex
okay hello I'm Alex I'm also in Moscow
Russia so welcome
everybody cool and Alejandra has been on
before so hopefully we know her but when
she jumps back in we can hear from her
so for these warm-up questions and also
it's pretty cool to have a slightly
smaller panel so I'm really looking
forward to hearing everyone's
perspective on what they got out of the
paper what they brought to the paper
it'll be really cool to hear about so
the first question is what made you
excited to read this paper and or to
learn about these
topics so while people are raising their
hand and feel free to do so something
that initially made me excited to read
this paper was just about learning how
active inference could be applied to the
kinds of problems that people apply
other machine learning algorithms to so
that's a starting point blue
so I picked this paper I um hadn't like
thoroughly like digested it when I when
I picked it I had read um the first
author's other paper in PL computational
biology but like applying um like agent
based models and like modeling
parameters to uh active inference was
was like really what intrigued me and
the um this paper I especially liked
because of the ability to apply it in a
continuous frame framework as as opposed
to like something in discret time steps
and I thought that that's that was
significant and
important cool welcome Alejandra do you
want to just give your quick intro and
say hi oh never mind uh anyone else want
to add something that made them excited
to learn about this topic or read about
the
paper yeah thanks again for the
suggestion blue the second question is
what is your experience or background
with computers SL comput ational
modeling and what is something
interesting that you've been learning
about or studying recently in the area
and I think that my goal with this
question was to show to our listeners SL
viewers that there's many computational
backgrounds that intersect in active
inference so it's a community that
includes some people who are really on
The Cutting Edge of the computational
modeling and that's what we see
reflected in this paper so big props to
everybody who is reading and talking
about it because it is at The Cutting
Edge of that type of machine learning
research but also there's this deep
tradition of action-oriented research
and embodied cognition and so many other
areas that might not necessarily uh
entail a computational background or
even a computational approach in how
they're studied until this type of
intersectional research so does anyone
want to just something that they've been
learning about in computers or what type
of computer modeling have they had
experience with so I can start a lot of
my computer work had been in
bioinformatics which does deal with
computers but it's very different kinds
of questions than the machine Learning
Community however increasingly there's
application of machine learning to
bioinformatics so this was just kind of
like a different perspective on machine
learning outside of the biological
contexts that I had mainly seen it in
and I'll just throw up the third
question in case anyone wants to answer
that one which is what kinds of problems
might machine learning based upon active
inference be applied to so you can just
raise your hand if you yep go ahead
Sasha um yeah I would say I guess to
some of all these questions is I have
very limited experience and working with
computers uh but my background is in
neuroscience and I'm always curious to
to um learn what uh machine learning um
has to offer for understanding the
process of learning and how that can
link back to neurobiology Concepts um
and so I'm interested in in
understanding these equations and having
uh a better grasp on um what the
relationships are
like cool because learning is really a
biologically inspired topic it's based
upon learning in organisms or the kind
of control that organisms enact in their
environment and that's not even getting
into the whole neural network SL actual
brain debacle so definitely these kinds
of learning questions any other thoughts
on this
one
blue so like you my background is like
bioinformatics but I've like branched
out since like getting out of doctoral
Research into like doing all kinds of
different
computational and agent-based modeling
type applications even Quantum Computing
a little bit um this system particularly
um interests me because like Sasha I'm
interested in learning like how things
learn but also like from the Beyond
brain perspective like stay in biology
but think about biological systems just
at a very simple level like slime molds
or something like this how do these
systems learn right because still
there's some element of learning that
happens and when you can kind of
deconstruct it into like a
computational like model then you can
start to like recognize input output
into simpler biological systems beyond
the
brain cool and let's return to that
multiscale cognition when we're a little
bit later on but I wrote that down so we
can definitely return there any last
thoughts on the warm-ups before we get
get into the
paper cool all right so today we are
going to be talking about this scaling
active inference paper which is an
archive paper and the paper presents its
goal as or what it does as we present a
model of active inference that is
applicable in high-dimensional control
tasks with both continuous States and
actions our model builds upon previous
attempts to scale active inference by
including an efficient planning
algorithm as well as the quantification
and active resolution of model
uncertainty our model makes two primary
contributions first we showed that the
full active inference construct can be
scaled to the kinds of tasks considered
in the reinforcement learning literature
this involved extending previous models
of deep active inference to include
model uncertainty and expected
Information Gain second we highlighted
the overlap between active inference and
state-of-the-art approaches to
model-based reinforcement learning
welcome back Alejandra and some of these
topics were introduced or at least
initially brought up in the ACT imp
stream 8.0 so if you're a little bit
just unsure what is modelbased versus
non-m modelbased reinforcement learning
or what is reinforcement learning or
what is machine learning it's all good
there's kind of a sequence of ideas that
you can follow to understand why this
paper is so exciting and just go to ACM
stream 8.0 if you're curious the way
that we can phrase what the Big Goal or
question of the paper is in terms of non
active inference uh vocabulary would be
how can we apply active inference to
challenging control tasks and like blue
mentioned these are the ones that often
involve continuous decisions being made
so like turning up a dial um or down or
steering wheel rather than like chess or
Checkers or Connect 4 or the Mario Kart
example which now I will never forget
and then how to connect these continuous
challenging control tasks which have
elements of planning and all these other
things happening and connect these tasks
formally to reinforcement
learning any thoughts or questions on
the goal of the
paper cool so the abstract which we'll
just run through is in reinforcement
learning RL agents operate in partially
observed and uncertain environments
isn't that the truth modelbased
reinforcement learning suggests that
this control of these partially observed
and uncertain environments is best
achieved by learning and exploiting a
probabilistic model of the world so just
to be clear this is what traditional
model-based reinforcement learning is
model free or unsupervised reinforcement
learning would be learning the very very
direct relationships between outcomes
like reward and States modelbased
reinforcement learning abstracts a
little bit above that and it considers
how learning occurs on a probabilistic
model of the world active inference is
an emerging normative framework in
cognitive and computational Neuroscience
that offers a unifying account of how
how biological agents achieve this
control in this framework inference
learning and action emerge from a single
imperative that maximizes the basian
evidence for a niched model of the world
and so learning inference and action are
all part of the organism's generative
model and we're going to see how that
gets specified and how it plays
out the challenge is that
implementations of this process this
integration between inference and action
if you will have thus far been
restricted to low-dimensional and
idealized situations so this could be
for example playing a very simple game
or doing a 2 by two Matrix like a
prisoners dilemma or there are other
cases where active inference has been
used for slightly higher dimensional but
still quite idealized situations like
reading from a known set of
options here we present a working
implementation of active inference that
applies to higher dimensional tasks with
proof of principal results demonstrating
efficient exploration and an order of
magnitude increase in Sample efficiency
over strong model-free baselines so just
by reading that we can look forward to
some improvements on classical
algorithms and as far as this magnitude
increase in Sample efficiency the reason
why they're focused on Sample efficiency
is because these distributions that we
want to understand the shape of are not
just like a simple curve there's a lot
of Dimensions to them and they're very
rugged so small changes can change your
height so to speak speak quite a lot
which means that the challenge is to
sample effectively not get trapped in
one area or not to over sample one
region at the cost of
another our results demonstrate the
feasibility of applying active inference
at scale and highlight the operational
homologies between active inference and
current model-based approaches to
reinforcement learning so what would be
the implications of that well it'd be
pretty epic if all of the hype and Buzz
that we hear about machine learning or
rein forcement learning or all the
places where we know reinforcement
learning gets applied ranging from
recommendation algorithms to maps to
just all these types of things could
active inference play a role in that and
what what would that do for our
conception of these kinds of algorithms
and there's probably a lot of directions
to take that but that's the equivalence
is if there is a homology and
potentially even a superiority of active
inference techniques in certain cases
over reinforcement learning then it
liberates us from some of the baggage of
the straightforward model-based uh
reinforcement learning or the critiques
of reinforcement learning but also opens
the door to some new ways to implement
strategies and understand the systems
that we're working
with cool so the paper has a pretty
clear road map this is like driving on
Highway 10 in New
Mexico and there's a introduction
section uh the relationship to further
work is actually section five which
we'll get to in a second but the paper
begins with an introduction and a
consideration of active inference as a
topic it then moves directly to the
model and lays it out in the six
subsections 3.1 through 3.6 from a
mathematical perspective we're going to
be focusing primarily on one two and
three because those are the parts that
we've heard the most about and they're
the most relatable so the generative
model and the recognition distribution
are the p and the Q mind your p's and
q's and this is everything that we've
been talking about with the two
directions between the agent and the
world and whether we think about that in
the basian structural computationalist
perspective or the an activist
perspective the whole tale of two
densities integrating internalism and
externalism all these things come
together in 3.1 3.2 learning and
inference is where we're going to draw
the bow together with reinforcement
learning and about other machine
learning algorithms
3.3 is where we're going to come closer
to control theory because we're going to
be talking about setting policies for
Action then 3.4 56 hopefully when Alec
is here next week we'll have a little
bit uh more detail there maybe we could
even see a simulation or hear about some
of the degrees of freedom that the
authors had in the model why they chose
to do what they did the part that will
be very cool as an experimental
biologist is the experimental section
and here it's an interesting approach to
do one set of tasks that conveys
exploration of a state space and another
set of tasks that conveys exploitation
so they're saying like this model has
two hands you know it's good at
exploring but it's good at exploiting as
well then there's the connection to
previous work and the three areas that
they tie it most directly to with the
keywords as well as in this closing
section are related to deep active
inference which in contrast to I guess
shallow active inference would mean that
you're not just minimizing your surprise
about your instantaneous sensory
information but you have a deep or a
counterfactual model that goes through
time so that's like the example of
taking a jacket even though you're not
cold yet that's deep active inference
you're reducing your surprise about
future states of your temperature under
a generative model where if you go
outside and it's cold you're going to
get cold but shallow active inference
would be like you wouldn't put on the
jacket or you wouldn't even take it with
you because it wouldn't be a relevant
affordance in the one second time frame
but it actually is relevant in the
1second time frame under a deep
generative model of temperature the
second two are model-based reinforcement
learning which we've mentioned a few
times and Information Gain information
is reduction of uncertainty and when
we're reducing our uncertainty about
environmental causes it helps us plan
better actions but we also need to
reduce our uncertainty about which
actions to take and that's called policy
and that's what Rel relates us here to
control theory then there's a discussion
and conclusion okay before we jump into
the math in the actual sections are
there any thoughts or questions on the
road
map all right here is a partial notation
reference and I just separate them onto
two sides and so if you're only going to
look at a few parameters uh if your
parameter overload hits in at six the
ones on the left are the important ones
these are the ones that will help you
get 80% of what is happening and then
the next 10% are the ones on the right
and then there's a few other ones which
aren't on this page that are more like
the esoteric statistical parameters the
big parameter is s with a hat just like
Sasha with a hat and that's the true
state of the environment so s with a hat
is what is actually trying to be
predicted and that's like the actual
temperature of the environment or the
actual amount of sunlight but that's not
what the agent is able to track directly
it's able to make an estimate of the
environmental State and you can imagine
there's times where that's an easy
estimate to make there's times where
it's a hard estimate to make and then
this is the difference between the
discret and the continuous case would be
if the state that you're estimating is
is it day or night it's a zero or one
that's a discrete case a continuous case
would be like what is the amount of
light and that's a continuous variable
so there's a lot more options a lot more
Shades of Gray infinite of them that's s
is the agent's internal ongoing estimate
of this environmental state state that
it's trying to track and we can think
about it with just one s or there can be
multiple s's like is it humid or is it
dry that's one axis another one is it
light or dark o are the observations so
in the case of light being estimated
that would be like the observations of
light on the retina in the case of
temperature it's like a thermometer
reading a are the policy actions by the
agent and those are arising from PI
which is a policy and a policy is like a
layer above action so for example action
would be moving my left foot my policy
would be if I hear this sound then I
move my left foot another policy would
be I always move my left foot and so
there's different kinds of policies that
can be very nuanced they can be
conditional they can be related to each
other or they can be very
straightforward and Standalone t with
italics is the time steps of the model
so this is just a modeling parameter
that's going to come up again and again
and it has to do with how time is
measured in terms of epochs or states or
continually okay then just to the right
side we have little and big Theta and
little Theta is often used just to mean
a parameter of the generative model and
the bigger Theta is like the space of
all the parameters so those are kind of
used similarly then Lambda is related to
the likelihood distribution it relates
some of the statistical parameters and
then f is the free energy and this
represents like if you could be on this
super smooth variational optimization
landscape just with just as if you would
really want to be following s hat but
you actually have to follow s with free
energy if we could be following F then
we'd be doing perfectly you just
strictly cannot do any better than that
however we can't directly track F so we
have to track G which is the expectation
of free energy which we'll also be able
to look at okay any thoughts or
questions on notation anyone seeing
similar notation to another field or a
difference is there something that we
want to that you'd imagine that a
control theory model would have that
isn't in
here all right anyone can just raise
their hand at any time I'm not sure
where several of our colleagues have
gone
to let's start by thinking about the
generative model so this is a generative
model P of a bunch of variables and this
is going to be kind of like what the
organism is slash does we're going to
leave for a second some of these uh
avenues that can be arising with the
niche symmetry which we've talked about
in the context of yellow bromberg's and
actual constants work and there's the a
lot of other things that we've brought
up let's just try to isolate what's
really relevant which is that the agent
is doing some type of implementation or
is some kind of an implementation of a
generative model of a couple of things
at once it's generating a model of
observations through time the Tilda on
top of a variable means through time so
observations through time and States
through time you can think of as a
function of policy choices pi and
parameters of the model Theta so for
example one of my parameters in my Theta
is like um if I get hit by a bike then
it's going to hurt and then my
generative model is like under the
policy of looking both ways to cross the
road I predict that my States will
include not being hit by a bike and so I
won't have any pain observations under
that same policy you could imagine um
other types of state and observation
predictions and then there are a few
subsequent mathematical details about
the insides of this equation it's a
little bit bracketed no pun intended in
the top and that's a shorthand and then
we can EXP explore and unpack it a few
more levels so like on that first row we
can see that that that p o Pi Theta
those um uh relationships can be
unpacked on the other side of the equal
sign the right hand side to like just
the probability of the parameters
existing and then just the probability
of the policy existing multiplied by
this big other thing so why would that
be the case and we won't go through all
of them in this detail but I think this
one's really helped ful to understand
for active inference and people just
raise your hand if you want to talk but
just to keep it like informational and
fun I'll just keep going until somebody
wants to ask a question so the reason
why P of Pi is there the probability of
the policy is like if the policy is
unrealistic you don't even want to
consider it you want to basically take
unlikely policies impossible or
implausible policies and systematically
not consider them so if if I'm trying to
get out of the way of the incoming bike
and I'm spending a lot of my time or my
clock Cycles or a lot of my cognitive
infrastructure on action strategies that
involve me doing a Spider-Man and
swinging from a building it's it's so
imp plausible that it's probably not
going to be effective so we want to have
something in our model that represents
likely or possible policies being
considered a little bit more richly than
impla implausible policies and similarly
for p of data which is a little more
abstract because it's just a parameter
of the model but it's like saying if
it's an unlikely parameter State it's
also not worth thinking too much about I
don't need to plan for it being -40 in
California however our Russian
colleagues might need a plan for that so
it's going to be Niche dependent and
contextual whether they need to plan for
it or not okay now let's go into this
big pie uh notation on the right side of
the right hand side of the first line of
equations this is kind of like a sigma
Sigma adds up the elements of a series
so like Sigma of you know 1 plus 1 over
two plus one over four or something and
the pi is like a big multiplier and it's
saying from the first time step T equals
1 through all of the time steps Big T do
this calculation what is the calculation
well it's the probability of
observations given States so and that's
observation out a certain time given the
state at that time so it's like if this
my estimate of the state not s hat just
s with hat if my observ if my state is
getting hit by a bike there's going to
be a very likely observation of it
hurting now that doesn't say whether
it's likely that I'm getting hit by a
bike it's just that it is the case if it
is that state then there's going to be
this observation so that's the mapping
between observations and States but it's
observations probability conditional
with a straight line on the state being
a certain way okay that's the first part
and the second part is the probability
of that state
arising conditional on
the previous state and the previous
policy and the parameter and so again
with this like bike model it's like what
is the probability of my estimated State
s oft at that time being hit by a bike
given that I wasn't being hit by a bike
before and my policy was looking both
ways and my Theta model parameters tell
me that if I look both ways it's really
likely that I'll stay safe for example
but stay safe isn't what's directly
specified by the model Theta it's
actually specifying the likelihood Ood
that a given policy and state mapping
are going to relate into the future with
a certain State and then separately we
can consider What observations arise
given a state so it's a little bit like
just showing our work or being very
clear with what is the actual state of
the world s hat what's the estimated
State s what are the um mappings between
policies States and future States that's
the right side then what's the mapping
between observ observations and states
in that first part okay any thoughts or
questions because the rest just kind of
continues from here in a similar way
um okay we'll just keep on you know
write down any cool questions that are
coming to mind Ivon yeah go
ahead well you're muted first but yes
then continue uh thank you uh could you
please explain one more time what's the
small Theta is it's parameter
of uh it's parameter
of the generative model but what is it
yes great question so we can actually
list we can go just just to show it in
the context of the
paper um and this by the way is in 3.1
but it introduces some of the other um
equations
earlier um
the Theta are the details of the model
that relate the transition distribution
so here we're looking at the states and
the previous policy the S tus1 and Pi of
tus one and how given Theta it maps on
to S of so what is Theta just from
looking at the equation what is Theta
going to be telling us it's going to be
telling us how to map T minus one's
State and policy State estimate and
policy to the time T States so let's
just imagine that it were a linear model
so I had a linear yal MX plus b and that
was how we were going to map forward
just totally a simple way to do it then
Theta would be like a vector containing
m and
b or Theta would the the how many
dimensions of the model there are is how
tall Theta is going to be in a sense but
Theta are the parameters of the model
that say what the transition
distribution
is so uh yeah if it was a linear model
then Theta is kind of like a wrapper
around the parameters of the linear
model which is the slope M and then the
elevation B If This Were a neural
network with a million parameters then
Theta would have a million parameters
but it's kind of specifying the
likelihood that the S of tus1 and Pi of
T minus1 map on to S of T so let's just
say that Thea were one it just always
mapped to one for some reason then it's
like whatever these two are it's going
to map to one that's like you know f ofx
equals one yeah that's the parameter
that's the simplest possible model is
whatever the previous States and policy
are we just map to one the next one
would be F of uh x equals you know
insert your model there and so it is a
statistical point about what's a
parameter of a model and like aren't
these all parameters aren't they all
variables aren't they all random
variables aren't they all going to be
variables in my python code yes to all
of them and that's why there's a little
bit of nuance and that's actually why we
go into the details here because you can
get pretty Tangled Up and Confused in
the gray Zone with what's a estimator
and what what is the what is the
scientist estimating what is the
organism estimating and a lot of times
when we just look at it it's a little
bit clearer and we can think about a few
layers of unpacking with the top most
level of understanding is this uh big p
top equation then we can unpack it and
Define well what does that really mean
how do we pull out the likelihood of the
parameters like the likelihood of theta
from the likelihood of policy from this
time dependent series how do we Define
the distribution of P of O of T given s
of T like the second line and so uh each
of these we get continue unpacking and
then each of them get specified in
functions in programming which hopefully
we'll hear from Alec about next week and
there sometimes it becomes another level
of uh Clarity when you look at the
function definition and you can say oh
this function is actually taking in
variable a b and c and then instead of
seeing them as just o subt s subt the
variable's name could be States through
time or there might be a more
descriptive name so I know that
especially if you haven't looked at
these equations for a long time or uh
perhaps many equations for a long time
sometimes like you get halfway down the
page it's like what what what is Mu of
theta again but it is referring to
something specific it's just a little
bit of a shorthand to make sure that uh
it fits visibly in a containable space
so any other thoughts but good question
there with the
parameters so just what are the other um
yeah yeah Sasha go
ahead um yeah thank you that was really
useful to walk through those steps
especially with the bike example and it
um kind of brings to mind uh cases of
when something is very unlikely to
happen but the um but it's certain to
have uh really bad outcomes so like uh
you know it's really going to hurt if
you get hit by a bike versus um things
that are very likely to happen but don't
have
uh but are not certain of having a bad
outcome like I don't know um
stubbing your toe on something um and so
these are things that are weighted
differently in in a model uh based on
the certainty of uh and the severity of
the outcome so I think that's really
cool that this is all incorporated into
one model yeah and when we specify why
we're making certain decisions first
we're just laying these equations out to
describe our little control theory robot
playing Mario Kart or playing control
theory games on N64 but what if people
had a a little bit more nuanced
discussion on Collective decision-making
topics like somebody thinks well I think
it's totally unlikely that the minimum
miles per gallon of cars could be 40
miles by 2030 and someone else says
that's super likely actually it's
totally possible it's totally likely I
think that it can be done or I think
that this other policy that you're
suggesting is implausible or that it
will have a bad outcome and so people
can disagree on whether a policy is
actualizable or not for various reasons
it might come across as an ethical
constraint or legal constraint or
logistical whatever it happens to be but
for whatever reason that P of Pi is low
for them and then we could unpack that
and say okay all these different
elements are there depending on the
situation and then somebody else might
say I'm with you on that outcome being
unlikely I just don't think it's that
big of a deal saying oh yep I think that
that kind of a tsunami will happen once
every hundred years but I think that my
transition Matrix from tsunami damage to
being repaired it just says that that's
an easy transition so we don't really
need to plan so heavily around it
because when it does happen we'll be
able to rebuild quickly for example so
these just allow us to give a little bit
more detail into our infrastructure
really our architecture of decision-
making and so I think blue that's
definitely where we can take it back to
this multiple scales of decision-making
question just to look through a couple
of these other equations before we move
to Q here is the probability model of
observations given States and so again
that's like if the state my estimated
State not s hat if my estimated state is
getting hit by a bike or stubbing my toe
the observations will be such and such
in my appropriate receptors and that is
given by a normal distribution which
means big n on the variable o of T and
semicolon parameterized by mu and sigma
squ which are the mean and the variance
and then those together mu and sigma
squar it turns out that those are the
hard parts to estimate just like the
problem or the challenge of doing a
linear aggression on a billion data
points point would be estimating the
mean and the variance so you could fit
the mean by adding up all the numbers
and then dividing it by the amount of
numbers and for fitting the variance you
could use like a least squares model but
still that would be the computation that
you could do on pen and paper but would
just be very hard in this case we're
going to be doing what is called a
amortized learning or a functional a
functional is like a function of another
function and what we're going to be
doing is estimating these statistical
parameters
with this function Lambda and then we're
going to fit the neural network about
that function Lambda and so even though
neural networks are often understood as
providing additional degrees of
flexibility like being able to learn
conditional relationships between data
um this took me a little bit to think
about but the neural network is actually
just facilitating Us in this model it's
not saying that it would have to be this
way for all future ACM learning but it's
actually still just fitting a neural
network model of a normal distribution
so we're finding the parameters mu and
sigma use it which are very difficult to
estimate as you can imagine for
nonlinear control task but we're still
fitting it with a function around um a
normal so it's kind of this interesting
juxtoposition of using Advanced
Techniques like a neural network um High
parametric techniques to actually drill
back down to a mean and a variance and
then so this is this p is this first
part of this um series and then s of
given the previous state and the
previous policy is the second part here
so this part here gets estimated with f
of Lambda and then the uh second half of
that series through time has another
normal distribution with uh mu of theta
and sigma squ of data and then those two
get looped up into uh a functional over
those two similarly like s of T is the
right hand side what's being conditioned
on and we're going to be estimating the
mean and variance of what is conditioned
on and then here it's similar we're
making a function that is estimating
what is being conditioned on okay then
we have this uh early parts of the
equation which is the probability of the
policy is basically um it's going to be
pretty simple in this case but this is
where you could have a lot more degrees
of flexibility this is sort of like an
initial skeleton paper as far as what
could be done with this framework and
that's kind of cool that's actually what
defines it in some ways as being
research and as being cutting edges this
isn't the fine tuning of the parameters
this is laying out the framework that's
going to help us in a lot of other
contexts and then the probability of the
policy this is the part where we
actually get to free energy okay so if
we remember from the notation slide f is
like the free energy where we strictly
couldn't be making any better decisions
if we knew that but G is the expected
free energy so just like s is the Hat s
with the hat is real state of the
environment that's like what we'd really
want to track and free energy would be
what our policy decisions would strictly
want to be converging upon but we don't
get S hat we get S and we don't get F we
get G what is g where does it come into
play well the probability of a policy is
now here Sigma is actually not this is
Sigma squar a statistical parameter and
it's kind of annoying but it is this way
that this Sigma is a soft Max function
which basically is like the make a
choice function in math it just is s for
soft Max here Sigma for variance here
and what this is going to be is the
negative expected free energy and
sometimes there's some negatives and
some logs getting thrown around and
these are all just ways to really just
say pick the best given the expected
free energy of policy and so this is how
we get to certain statements which have
definitely been discussed on this uh
live stream before where it's like the
agent picks the most likely policy and
it's like wait but is it likely for me
to win or lose what if it's a I know
that it's unlikely for me to win or lose
um if it's one in 100 that I'm going to
win how is that me picking the most
likely policy but that's actually what
um is happening but it's not just simply
the likeliest policy um there's a little
bit more Nuance which we'll look into
with G okay so that was sort of the P
side let's maybe a little bit more
quickly because we will recognize a lot
of the variables and also a lot of the
structural relationships between
equations here's the CU
so we have p and Q between the agent and
the environment uh in a sense these are
the two distributions that are linking
it not that one is being computed by one
or one is computed by the other but
thinking about in that basian
computationalist framework where we have
like the data going in one model goes to
the hyperparameters and then the
hyperparameters generate leading to um
the uh Hey Shannon welcome back if we if
yeah um going back to the observed
states of the world so Q um is going to
be distinguished from p p is this
implementation of the generative model
of the world where is Q is going to very
distinctly have different parameters
instead of P Pi Theta here we have q of
s Through Time policies in Theta so this
is a slightly simpler uh mathematical
formulation and it is going to be
unpacked as Q of the states through time
and the policy and the model parameters
is again uh we see the likelihood of the
model parameters and the likelihood of
the policy coming out in front um and
these are similar to the P but P doesn't
have to equal q and then a slightly
simpler uh piece here which is just
about the states given the
observations uh and so this is like
literally given the retina Shadows what
is the state estimate of the world so
this is um it's like here in in P if we
look at just this uh Second Line This is
the probability of observations given
States so this is given that it's
daytime there should be a lot of photons
if the estimated state of the world is
nighttime there shouldn't be any photons
p o s okay but it's O given s now in Q
we actually have S given o so the p is
different than the Q but also the orders
have switched this is a called a
recognition distribution because we're
basically doing an estimation of the
states given the observations so Q is
kind of like the incoming way that the
observations are going to be connected
to the state estimators of the world
that's the recognition but then the
generative model which is the P that
entails understanding what the hidden
states of the world are s and your
estimates of them that is and then
generating out
observations that are linked up to
policy and so here there's a slightly
different way that the parameters of
this model and that the um policy
mapping is done with these uh few more
statistical parameters but similarly
which we don't need to go into too much
detail in here is these are also going
to be distributed using some statistical
distribution that's going to help us
estimate them and similarly we can take
all the statistical parameters so for a
normal distribution it's a two parameter
model mean invariance but you could have
uh distributions with one or with more
than two variables but whatever number
of statistical variables you want to
estimate we're just going to wrap them
into a function and figure out some way
to estimate them and so that's a uh uh
degree of Freedom you can think of in
the model is that uh there's different
you could flip out this normal for some
other type of distribution or you could
have another way to estimate the
distributions uh normality okay that's p
and Q but it is really important and
interesting what they are any thoughts
or questions or we can just keep
cruising okay yeah um
Alex uh yeah I want
to ask uh maybe in terms of uh so P is
for generative model Q is for
recognition distribution and recognition
model and as we discussed in previous
session generative
model exists or acts uh in uh Dynamics
so you have uh generative model in some
way of it's like was example with
Domino so when you act and act in
accordance to this generative model and
an example of Road and and a bike
this generative model defines way you
are looking on both ways and when go if
you don't see a buy and uh in this terms
so what will be recognition distribution
recognition model it's will be
understanding how bike is looks like or
what is how how road is looks like and
so on or it's the wrong direction for my
understanding a good question and it was
it was actually I had had to email Alec
to clarify a few things because I looked
at this Q distribution I thought wait
it's a recognition distribution but
where are the observations how can Q be
recognition when there's no observations
and then it turns out there are
observations that are uh related to q
but it's he just said basically it's the
norm in the recognition distribution
literature like this part of the basian
computational fields this is what they
call those two models the recognition
distribution which is from the
observations to the generative model
parameters which ironically as a norm
doesn't include the uh observation and
then the generative model again is the
one that's going from the organisms
parameter estimates of the world to
predicted observations and that's how
expectation maximization works now we
had all these interesting discussions
Alex which you're alluding to of for
example does the organism have the
internal model that's generative or is
the generative model enacted terms of
the relationship is it that's the
internalism versus externalism
discussion that we had so I'm going to
try to combine what Alec inform me about
as well as Channel a little Maxwell here
and I think the answer is going to be
there's multiple philosophical lenses
that you could
apply um to real world situations and
this is only what is specified in the
math and in the programming and so if
you include it if you include in your
recognition distribution is the uh
luminosity and the edge and the color
and those are the observations and
you're recogniz you're doing image
classification on recognizing a bike I'm
just simplifying it but there it is then
that is strictly only what is in the
recognition distribution it's going to
be about the mapping of the observations
um to of the states given observations
and your observations could include
those variables that we just talked
about so if it's being conditioned on
that then that's what's happening and
then even given a single form ization of
like okay the observations are the um
overall brightness and the amount of
movement or something like whatever it
happens to be it could still be a a
pluralistic philosophical scenario where
somebody could say okay that's a
modeling convenience but really those
observations are in the space between
the organism and the environment and
someone else says yep it's a modeling
convenience but I think those parameters
are something about the neural firing
and someone else says it's both of them
and someone else said so I would be open
to
uh correction and also would love to
hear Alex perspective on this but I
think the answer would be these papers
that we read Tale of Two densities and
integrating externalism and internalism
are actually about how by Framing it
within active inference we move Beyond
those philosophical debates or another
way to say that is build a bigger tent
that includes both of those perspectives
um in a way that's compatibilist because
those are the debates that people had
about these models so like in the
reinforcement learning literature it's
like okay is the reward the signal you
know is it a pleasing you know aesthetic
body form is that the reward or is that
the signal of the reward and if it is
the reward then isn't that a circular
definition like organisms seek out
what's rewarding but it's not like you
just want to see the Aesthetics there
might be some second intention for
example and so how do you actually draw
out these questions is it happening in
the organism head with a reward or is it
enacted and that was sort of the
philosophical groundwork and now we're
for a minute putting those bags of all
different stripes down and looking at
just the way that we're going to specify
it and how it plays out in simulations
knowing that potentially one person
might have a basy and structural
computationalist perspective of these
examples we're going to look at in a
second and somebody else might take a
heavily inactive example they might say
oh well the the cart that's on the hill
it's like the cart Hill combo organism
that's being or something like that but
at the end whether the person thinks
that it's inacted or it's just a basy
and computationalist approach they're
still going to at least be able to point
to the same equations and ultimately the
same code as well so that's like a
hopefully explanation of how the active
inference framework and the specifics
end up unifying these General debates
which potentially without such a
unifying framework it'd be intractable
cuz somebody would say okay well I think
that Q is happening in the brain of the
organism somebody else says I think that
Q happens in between the niche and the
organism someone else says I think Q is
a modeling shorthand someone says I
agree with person one and three or one
and two and now we're saying okay
they're kind of all correct they just
all ways that we can phrase the
specifics of what we're talking about
here so not that everyone's correct
because everyone's correct and there is
no wrong answer but under this
reconceptualization of action and
inference we find that some of these
previous questions are phrases in become
like yes and instead of either
slor okay to move a little bit more
quickly just through these uh a few
equations before we can I think just
highlight a little bit on the
experiments and then probably return to
the multiscale question that we talked
about earlier and also about what other
areas could control be interesting in
and also what questions would we want to
ask Alec and other attendees next week
here is equation one and this I put
after because I think it helps to
understand that P and Q and the mappings
but this is what is ultimately being
minimized so again we don't get F that's
the real free energy and that's um the
one that we would really want to be
converging towards which as they put it
um converging towards an approximation
of the posterior distribution of prob
the P model of States policies and
parameters given observations so that
would be like the best possible
State trajectory through time and the
best possible policy given the
observations of the world you know given
that Bitcoin is at this value and
ethereum is at this value the state
trajectory that's the best for me
entails this policy so that's clearly
what we want to know but that is
intractable so we needed to use some
type of a convergence towards this
intractability and this is where a lot
of the more specific and technical
details related to for example the colc
lier informational Divergence the the
informational distance between two
distributions is related because um
there's some those distance metrics are
bounded at zero like you if two
distributions are identical their
distance is zero and as they get more
and more distant that number strictly
increases and so it turns out that
there's some ways to have like this
hypothetical perfect distribution and
then have a distance between where
you're really at and this hypothetical
perfect distribution which is always a
positive distance and then try try to
converge towards that hypothetical
perfect position by minimizing the
distance function and that distance
function is informational but it still
is a distance metric in a certain
way and wrote out a few details um the E
is the expectation so it's expectation
of States Through Time policies and
model parameters and it's going to be
something that combines the Q and the P
the natural log which makes it a little
bit easier to do the machine learning
technique and a few other benefits
scaling it and bringing certain values
below the number line and then that is
going to be always greater than or equal
to that's this part right here than just
the obser the observations so it turns
out that by doing this estimator we can
bound um some a b there's a few things
that get bounded but they're not even
all phrased
here
um yep so I the last thing I wrote there
was given that the Q is um focusing on
basically between p and Q you get all
the parameters so what you can do by
optimizing the recognition density and
the generative model back and forth
whether actually like a two cycle engine
like expectation maximization which is
how it gets implemented in code or
dynamically and continuously as in the
case of an active organismal Behavior
what has to get learned upon but here
what tractably can be learned on and
conditioned upon is that mapping of how
observations States and policies are
linked in a nuanced Nexus where they're
all taken into account rather than
running a classifier that goes from just
observations to States and then a second
layer model from states to policies that
would be a little bit more along the
lines of traditional machine learning
but this is why it's different
approach okay then um again we don't get
G uh we or we don't get F we we only get
G so here is another phrasing of f
that's being played out through
time so here is um building on three and
four we're looking at the variational
free energy not just for an instant here
this is like a kind of Timeless
understanding of free energy you don't
see T in here it's through time with the
S Tilda and the O Tilda but it's like
not a specific times and then this one
is actually a function through time this
is observation T so this is like that
specific observation and then here's
where we see the Divergence the D
distance Divergence the KL distance
between the Q and the p and those are
not usually exchangeable so like it's
not like driving between two cities so
this um section again you can unpack
some of what the equations actually say
but this learning in inference section
talks about how to update or uh do
inference do learning based upon the
data of these
parameters here is where we get to G so
we don't get F we only get to estimate G
so the way I kind of broke this down was
we we want to do more than just update
our internal model to bounce Sur prise
on observations so if all you wanted to
do was test retest accuracy on an image
classifier data set all you'd have to do
would be bound surprise on Cross
validated versions of that data um or on
uh uh subsample or testing and training
splits but we want to actually do a few
different things we want to reduce our
uncertainty in the future so that's to
the or the curs of T I don't know which
way You' say it um in terms of the
policies that we take now so it's quite
different than just minimizing our
surprise about a linear aggressor given
a static data set we want to reduce our
uncertainty about observations in the
future as a function of the policies
we're taking now and this minimiz this
tractable expected free energy function
G takes as arguments policy and the
future time point so as a function of
the policies that are um available and
you know two years in the future how am
I going to um manage certain aspect of
life and it's going to be an expectation
that's conditional on um uh several
things conditional mainly we can
highlight is conditional on policy we're
doing an expectation that's conditioned
on policy because we wanted know
something about the states of the world
and the observations and the the
estimated states of the world as well
given a policy and then that is going to
be strictly bigger um and so natural log
that means that it's like basically
worse um in some ways but it depends a
lot on whether it's like positive or
negative that's kind of confusing stuff
sometimes um like whether it's a
negative log or like the subtracting or
the positive log and what it's always
bigger than is the negative expectation
of The observed states in the future
given a policy me here's me observing
that I have 50 Bitcoin um and that's
this part two the P of observations
given policy so what what I'd really
like to know would be uh some type of
model that just tells me what states I
can expect in the future What
observations I can expect in the future
um which relate to the States because of
the uh estimating the states given the
observations but here we're going for
the observations given the policy
and it's the uh log and then uh this
last part is kind of the important part
which is the log of the generative model
which is the observations given the
policy that's how things will go that's
well if we take this policy on miles per
gallon then we will go between uh you
know 1.5 and 2 degrees C now there's so
many degrees of freedom that go into
that but that's like what we'd want to
estimate would be relating how policies
literally are going to play into
observations which then tell us about
states of the world estimated like S
without a hat which should be hopefully
related to S with a hat the real states
of the world but still the focus here is
on the observations that are conditioned
on policy that kind of takes us to
policy selection and they write that
policy selections achieved by updating Q
in order to re to minimize F via G and
the uh need for this paper was that when
you have a short temporal Horizon you
can just run out every possible policy
like every possible set of five chest
moves or every possible set of all the
Tic Tac Toe moves there can't be more
than nine moves in a game every single
step if the branching is small and the
time Horizon is short you can evaluate G
in full so it becomes rather than
sampling over a distribution literally
just calculating a table and then
sorting however when you have deep
temporal Horizons you can't really
evaluate the full branching tree because
there's too many options so you have to
sample from that distribution so that's
the sampling problem the second Pro and
that's the Deep uh counterfactual
sampling problem which is even difficult
under uncertainty the second part is the
Mario Kart Paradigm which is that in
continuous action spaces there are
infinite policies meaning that some
other way is going to have to come into
play because not just are we sampling uh
deep through time we're sampling
potentially related to counterfactuals
which there's infinite counterfactuals
and we're talking about continuous
action spaces where there's act infinite
policies so if my only trading
affordances are should I have zero or
one or to bitcoin then I could ask which
one of those three options discreetly is
better but if there's infinite and I can
do continuous variables uh even smaller
than one you know breakdown it's like
then should I do
1.1 what if that's very different than
1.2 now you might say well those two
should be super similar and you should
be able just to sample every little
interval and estimate the distribution
right if it's a smooth distribution then
it's going to be easy to optimize maybe
you could discretize it maybe you could
do some other way to do smooth
optimization but the problem is actions
and policies are not smooth so maybe if
you're going into that turn in Mario
Kart you could uh aim at the corner and
just try to take it as fast as you can
or you could slow down and do a slightly
different angle or you could do some
other skidding maneuver so there's
multiple Separate Ways you're going to
be able to take this turn potentially
with different risks and reward and
they're all very nuanced so that is why
the Deep through time and counterfactual
aspects respectively uh which aren't as
much dealt with here counterfactuals but
through time absolutely is and then the
continuous actions which is really the
key introduction of this model that
takes it out of the Paradigm of
classifying images and puts it into the
Paradigm of continuous control theory
and then it turns out that that there's
a lot of trajectories Through Time given
how things can go and so there's some uh
implementation of a way to sample
trajectories that is utilizing what's
called a Monte Carlo sampling approach
or MC and uh there's the marov chain
Monte Carlo sampling mc mc mc squared um
and Monte Carlo just means that it's uh
related to Monte Carlo being a card
playing reference
in English and it's like the way that
you can shuffle a deck is so big how are
you going to estimate the number of ways
that you can get a royal flush or a pair
of fours or something like that instead
of just actually doing well it's 1 and
24 * 1 and 52 * 3 over 52 the way you do
it is you just sample randomly and then
you say okay I took a billion samples
and 1 million of them had this feature
and then you just take the ratio as your
estimate so it's a sampling and that
kind of hearkens back to earlier where
we wanted to talk about getting the
efficient sampling cuz that's kind of
what it's about is in the marov um or
sorry in the Monte Carlo sampler which
could be marov chain based um we want to
get good sampling we don't want to
sample only the hands with a royal flush
like if we had a a poor randomizer
because then we're going to get an
estimate that's wrong all right then
they go into a little bit more detail
about the G the estimated or the
expected free energy which is still as
it was before about policy in the future
and now it's going to be uh this broken
down and this is also where they draw
some of the homologies to reinforcement
learning and info gain into the uh the
informational gain kind of like the
reward and the info so this is where the
explore exploit also comes into play
which is that if one is only optimizing
locally they may be exploiting they may
be getting reward for a short period of
time but then it doesn't lead to a um
uh like we'll see it in the hill climber
example but if you just reward only and
only exploit sometimes you don't do very
well but if you just explore you might
not ever get to exploit anywhere good
and so the whole tradeoff and the whole
challenge of modeling is this balance
between explore and exploit between
searching deeply and searching broadly
and so the Holy Grail would be the right
way to search deeply down the routes
that are interesting and informative but
not down the ones that don't tell you
that much but we don't know which paths
are going to be informative or not until
we go down them however if we have a
deep generative model we can say in
terms of me winning this chess game this
branch is not informative for me to
search down not because there aren't
trillions of options but because I have
two castles and they have no pieces
other than their king so I'm going to
win so in terms of me winning it doesn't
give me any information to keep on
searching down that route I already know
I'm going to win and then there might be
another aen where there's fewer options
per se like less branching but there's
more uncertainty that's resolvable more
info gain is possible with respect to
the policies and
winning all right let's just do a little
bit on the experiments before we close
out so the two experiments that they go
into so hopefully all of you
experimentalists um by Sasha um
hopefully all you experimentalists will
like this part and the two examples are
the mountain car and the uh inverted
pendulum task and the hopper task so the
mountain car is an example of
exploration so what's being leared is
the policy between position and velocity
and then getting higher up the reward
function is like getting higher up and
so the car doesn't have a strong enough
engine just to drive up to the flag so
it's got to drive up and then the
perfect policy would be at right when
you're stopped flip the engine into
reverse and keep it in reverse until you
stop on this side and then get a little
bit higher up this way but this shows
you why you can't locally optimize why
you need to explore because let's just
say you're driving uphill you're slowing
down you're slowing down you start
slipping back slipping back and you're
like no stay on the gas continue
accelerating forward now you're slowing
your descent so when you get to here
you're not moving that fast so then when
you're on this side you'd say no no I
still want to get to the flag and so
you'd end up just sort of like being
very shallow down and focusing a lot of
your time here on the um middle and on
the right side so if you just simply
move towards the flag you're probably
not going to get there if the engine is
too weak however if you actually say I
want to explore I want a policy that
helps me increase my range so I want to
go as far as I can here and then wow if
I enact a policy where as soon as I hit
my Maxima I just try to explore further
this way and then I enact a policy
Switch and Go back to going this way wow
I might actually reach the goal purely
as a function of exploring now again
this is like a little model situation
where it turns out that exploring does
help one realize the goal that's not
always the case but it's it isolates
that feature of the model needing to be
able to explore the second case in the
exploit paradigms it's usually a little
bit more obvious what needs to be
exploited and about whether you're doing
it well or not so in the inverted
pendulum task it's like a railroad car
on a rail and there's a heavy ball M
that's on top of this pendulum it's
inverted and then the car can like move
backwards and that kind of moves this
joint to the left and that pushes the um
Pendulum In this case would straighten
it out whereas if this car starts taking
off to the right then this pendulum is
just going to fall and so the reward is
the height of the pendulum so it's
trying to maximize its reward by
enacting a policy and so the policy
that's best would be to keep on
exploiting that perfectly straight up
line where you actually are in the zone
of optimal control and then the exploit
task on the right is about uh increasing
the distance that's traveled by a little
jumping thing does anyone else have any
like thoughts on explore exploit or um
what what else does that yeah goad
blue so this I thought was super
interesting um as I was unpacking this
paper so and maybe I should just kind of
like lay a little bit of this out there
so the reward is only given in this
extrinsic value which is like the
exploit portion of the free energy
equation like given in number six and so
you know I don't know you didn't say it
explicitly but like here in the
exploration experiments the reward just
uses that um exploit parameter and
doesn't do any exploration based on
state or parameter Information Gain and
then in the exploit task it only uses
that exploitation parameter so like
there's no need for exploration I just
thought that that was super interesting
and like what would happen if they
included exploration in this explor in
the
exploitation um Paradigm so like why did
they leave that out like it was just
kind of weird to me cool good question
like that makes me think about let's say
there's some parts of the railroad track
where it's different angles and so yes
you want to maintain the pendulum being
upright but also you might want to
explore around a little bit to find a
region where you can control it better
so that actually makes me think of like
doing a track stand on my bicycle
there's some times where there's some
slopes of pavement that are easy to do a
track stand on and some are really hard
to do it but the way you get from a hard
position into an easier part of payment
you have to explore and that means
breaking the track
so definitely real control tasks are
related to the combination of explore
and exploit why did they use these two I
think that the reason why and let's hear
from Alec as to the real answer is that
these are part of the open AI
benchmarking set of like little micro
computable benchmarks for learning
algorithms here's the open ey AI um
let's see if we can even open it here
yeah so like here's their website and uh
there's a bunch of uh documentable cases
that allow comparison between different
machine learning algorithms and so I
think they're just outlining the minimal
single dimensional like sort of extreme
classic test cases there's a ton of
cases where we can already see it
wouldn't work like a double pendulum
that's chaotic or there's other kinds of
things that this model just doesn't even
try to do but this allows us to directly
compare two other algorithms on the
exact same t task instead of inventing
something that would like either not
take advantage of active inferences
strength or be like kind of an unfair
example by making it too nuanced like if
we added in a a reward another type of
something that a generative model could
take advantage of then we couldn't
compare it to some of these other agents
that don't use that kind of
information is that I just think they
were using the minimal case to to
demonstrate what explore and exploit
could look like and then future work
hopefully would be about things that
involve both right and so I get that and
but it just was like interesting to me
then I guess because the there's no
reward in the exploit parameter that
that's why they had to keep the exploit
parameter in the explore task do you
know what I mean like what I I just
wonder what would be the results if you
took out the exploit parameter from the
explore task would it then not succeed
because it just would wander around
aimlessly or would wandering around
aimlessly or like without a reward to
get get higher would that just produce
like a random result do you see what I
mean I I see what you mean so there
there's there's one there's one driving
strategy where it's truly just making
policy that's unrelated to its elevation
and um that depending on how that plays
out it might get somewhere it might not
most likely not because the space of the
strategies with relationship to getting
the flag is low but yes I I I I agree
that's an interesting question like when
is it enough to just explore like when
is novelty search simply enough when
might novelty search be strictly the
best when might novelty search 80% plus
20% let's keep a little reminder of our
elevation when might that be a relevant
and tractable strategy which parts of
these explore and exploit are
calculable um for example it might make
sense to evaluate or exploit a current
distributional uh value but how do we
explore the space of economic strategies
like I can't explore every single
possible economic strategy but I might
be able to exploit some ratio by doing
Arbitrage so there's some control tasks
where the exploitation is really
straightforward and visible and the
exploration is hard and then there's
other ones where um maybe this car can't
see the flag so maybe exploring is the
only thing it can do and so the really
great question those are kind of
interesting about these things being
traded off so there's the explore
exploit tradeoff and how that gets
implemented there's also the model
adequacy minus complexity which is we
want a good model but not too complex or
overfit one so there's no a prior best
way to trade off those two and then um
there there's just all these interesting
trade-offs that we can explore the space
of let's just look at what the results
were so here the x-axis is like where
positions is from the other side farther
to um 0.5 which I guess could be the
flag uh or at least close to it I try to
line it up maybe it's the way or
something like that but we can see that
the position of the greedy agent who
just drives up up up up up and says no
and then just goes up up up up no this
one stays tightly bounded in uh a medium
velocity uh regime and within a sort of
sampling a ton from this part of the
distribution think about that like an
upside down bell curve and it's like
sampling a ton from right here but it's
not sampling from up here so that's how
there's a relationship between sampling
and control because to get to certain
States it's like sampling those States
the Epsilon uh greedy uh agent which has
a slightly different implementation it
does sometimes appear to get outside
maybe by the end of its 100 EPO it was
starting to take some trips out further
but and at slightly higher uh speeds and
slightly further out but it doesn't
spend most of its time doing so the
active inference learner of course they
wrote the paper so it's going to be the
one that succeeds but it does in 100
epox learn very fast fast and it does
get to some pretty high speeds and some
pretty distant
positions and then just briefly to like
compare it with the other
task the two exploit tasks are laid out
here and they are comparing it to this
ddpg agent which is a model-free learner
and so people can look into details or
one could imagine that maybe there's
other algorithms they could test it
against these are all the kinds of
things we can ask Al about but we can
see that um a which is the same as c c
is just the first part of a it just
zoomed in on really close but it's like
right away in both of these after either
like five epochs like five trials five
seconds or um after maybe 30 or 40 or 50
the active inference learner just starts
to take off in terms of once it's hit on
a solution sometimes it just it strictly
improves it with some noise whereas the
um
ddpg the two things that you see are
first off at spends a ton of time near
the Baseline so it takes a while before
it locks on to any useful combination of
parameters and then when it gets off
Baseline it ends up um sometimes
succeeding but still um it's like
perhaps because it's locally optimizing
or we can ask why it is but they're just
not sampling highly rewarding States
even after it gets off the Baseline it
does stay off Baseline but it doesn't
ever get as high as the active inference
learner does extreme ex rapidly so this
is kind of where they're drawing their
evidence for the claims about the
potential superiority or preference for
active inference now yes you could
probably train a ddpg on some massive
data set and get better performance than
they got they probably just used a
straightforward implementation so that's
where research happens that's what
people study is okay well can we do a
ddpg whatever that is plus this other
feature that is being used by this other
group or what is it that actually
causing the active inference learner to
get off the ground so fast and could we
even get it off the ground faster in the
case of this Hopper task or could we
make a more reliable reward function for
the inverted pendulum task but this is
control theory at its finest really and
so this is what it's all about is
learning policies that map states onto
reward those are the key pieces that's
why we spent so much time talking about
the equations that are relating between
observation
State estimates and policies because
that's what it's all about is the
observations coming in and then the
policies being selected based upon the
estimated states of the world and then
actions coming out that's the marov
blanket of the organisms perspective at
least and then outside uh World in these
examples is simple and unchanging like
gravity is gravity for the pendulum and
for the hopper and it's not changing but
we can start to think about well what if
there was uh a dial gravity Rhythm how
would the control theory change well
there could be a generative model in the
agent control uh mapping of those p and
Q that involved some sort of is it day
or night and then I have a conditional
policy whether I think it's day or night
so we can kind of see how it starts
adding layers there and yeah that's
basically it but let's have any last
thoughts does anyone like what was
something cool or unexpected what's
something they'd like to ask Alec about
or that they're curious to learn more
about
now chill Oh Shannon go
ahead hey um yeah so I was thinking
about um Blue's question and why not use
the um exploration component in these
inverted pedum and Hopper tasks and
wouldn't it be because there's kind of
only one state that is maximum reward so
if we're completely vertical or if we
hop as far as possible but if there were
potential states that would have
differing values of reward then we might
expect to see something different if we
use the the exploration component of the
active reference model great Point like
if it were a bodal distribution then you
can't just try to keep it as close to
the maximum height as possible because
you wouldn't know if you were locally
optimizing or globally optimizing and
you might want to be sampling across the
whole distribution just so you know or
you might want to spend a lot of time at
rewarding States but still have some
understanding of the Total distribution
to understand if there might be more
rewarding states that you're just not
visiting at all that is the whole
challenge of local and Global
optimization and so you're right that in
this mountain car example local
optimization is global you're going to
get to the best flag just by by you know
so to speak I know it was was in the
explore strategy but in this one it's
clear as you brought up if you're having
the pendulum at the maximum height
You're simply doing as well as you can
period you don't need to explore other
ways you could do Loop to Loop and
that's the challenge though is you got
to you got to walk through the valley of
death to get from the local Optima to
the global and that's where these
algorithms uh dare not tread because
they have to walk through improbable or
non preferable like moving away from
your target States in order to get to
the next Peak which might be absolutely
higher in the exploit Paradigm or might
reveal new territory in the explore
Paradigm so there's reasons why you want
to get through the valley of low
likelihood whether you're exploring or
exploiting or a
combination and that is where there's so
many options there's so many weeds and
tangles in the valley that the way that
we're going to cut through it with a
machete is infog gain and we're going to
explore paths through the valley that
are the most informative for us given
our understanding of our own policies
and so that's like if you have a 4x4
versus a small team versus you're a
drone different policies different
affordances mean that you're going to be
exploring this Valley differently and
then there's whether you're exploring
for the sake of exploring and learning
new turf or whether you're exploiting
because you just want to have uh high
elevation or whether it's a little of
both those are all some Nuance you can
add in but the inside of active
inference is like let's actually think
about what would be informative
trajectories to take through that Valley
based upon a generative model of the
landscape and taking our own policy
affordances into account if you don't
have a generative model of the landscape
you're going to be doing something like
locally just going downhill or locally
going uphill so you need a deeper
generative model of landscape and if you
don't take your affordances into account
then you're lost because you might be
unknowingly optimizing something that's
going to be appropriate for you know
know the uh drone to fly over but then
you're on the ground so you actually
can't make it up that hill but it's a
policy that might work for a different
organism and it's just not the one that
works for you I know we're kind of like
mixing metaphors but I think it's a fun
way to think about these optimizations
because we are implementing Control
process something that we modeled with
control theory and then also we're
seeing it play out in like a very
abstract computational framework
here cool stuff metors yep so then they
talk about the relationship with
previous work I think I'll just put it
on the screen people can um pause it if
they want to look but with that I'll
just say thanks to our cohort here for
participating super interesting stuff
and next week we hope to have Alec on to
discuss some of these questions so you
can check the calendar event to provide
a follow-up survey where you can add
some details how could we improve or
what questions would you like to hear
conveyed in 8.2 and and for those who
are not participating live please
provide us with feedback or suggestions
or questions that we can cover and just
uh stay in touch but that was really
great so thanks a lot everyone for the
discussion